you
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the Africa
business club's Q&A for Stanford
Graduate School of Business
my name is Ruth Levinson I am from
Nigeria and I'm joined here today with
three amazing panelists so catalyst if
you can introduce yourself say your name
where you're from and what you hope to
do after business school cool so my name
is Kevin I'm from Uganda before business
school I was running a company back home
where the kinsey for the summer
and I'll be joined in McKinsey after
visible hi everyone thanks for telling
in my name is Eugene I'm from Kenya
before the GSB I was working for the
International Finance Corporation in
London and before that I worked for an
asset management firm in Nairobi and
after business school I'm hoping to work
in a private equity space in Africa
hello everyone my name is Lonnie day
before business school I was in McKinsey
for three years I was working in the
legal office for two and learning London
for a year in Business School have
actually transitioned a lots I worked in
space tech event summer in Google X and
after business school I'm still not sure
I'm going to do an average go back to
Google or Daniken's okay and I also
introduced myself like I said I'm Ruth
I'm from Nigeria I did public accounting
before Business School as well as did
some work on the continent of Africa
different countries and different
capacities which we can get to a little
bit later and after business school I am
one of those people who also have a few
options I'll either do big tech or do
something on my own
but it has to focus on emerging markets
so as long as the one of the
co-presidents of Africa business club
I'm super excited to bring this webinar
I'll see you guys today
our lovely Stanford initiator he's
informed us that this has been a huge
there have been huge signups for this
webinar but 300 people signed up so it
does seem like we have
ton of people from the continent or
connected to the continent of Africa in
some way who are interested in life as
African student at the GSB so I'm super
excited for you guys to start a
conversation with you guys so one is ask
one first question so when did you guys
decide to apply to Stanford and what
made you guys choose Stanford over other
schools anybody can come first as well
as I think I decided to apply the
Stanford perhaps one year before I
applied and I was so I had lived in
water Europe for almost three years and
I thought it would be great to actually
come study in the US and also how would
be to have an American experience before
returning to work in the continent the
reason I chose Stanford is because I
wanted a school that was really
committed to the African continent and I
think over the last five or so years
we've seen Stanford probably too much if
not more than any other school I happen
to interact with this time pussied
program which is being around of Nigeria
Ghana and Kenya and I met some of the
Stanford see the alum I also met some of
the students would come here and at this
time but Africa so huge ethicist
is a strong statement by Stanford they
actually really committed in Africa's
future so that's that ready to know
history school I can do next
I decided to fly in I said I want to
come in 2015 and the previous Dean of
Admissions Director and most in Uganda
talking about the GSB and to put it
bluntly I fell in love and then sigh
speaking to a bunch of students alums
and the main reason about it come here
is Tom's the people just interacting so
many people who are super impressive but
also down-to-earth and genuinely kind
people was a place I wanted to to be
like everything else I thought to us was
amazing curriculum school in general but
it came for me dance the people who had
spoken to interact with right and then
just to build on what Kevin said so when
I was thinking about science Business
School
as I said I was in McKinsey before and
actually the Africa office had had a lot
of people go to their MBA but no one had
come to Stanford and when I was thinking
about planes at business school I think
for me the biggest thing was I really
wanted to know myself more and I wanted
to be in a program that allowed me to
explore myself exploring some
interpersonal dynamics and Stanford is
the kind of place way that is encouraged
and that is allowed you have a
permission and almost the support to go
deeper into yourself so that was life
science can stop it
amazing thank you so I do know
personally all of you guys did not live
in the United States before he started
Stanford and I visited but you haven't
lived in the United States so I'm
curious to understand how that
transition was for you guys to the Bay
Area
oh man so Stanford I think it was
surprisingly easy for me compared so did
my undergrad in the UK and it was super
difficult me too that transition from
Canada to England but to the u.s. it was
a lot easier it might be a function of
age I came to us 27 but also I think
it's a function of the community here is
so many people willing to help you
understand what's happening compass
second year was great
Africa business club atmosphere
Association everyone interacted with was
super helpful in helping me adjust to
living the US and so I looking back I
should not have had any worries or
making a move here it was pretty easy
should thank you yeah I think for me it
was my one school in the UK like half
the first few weeks it did take
something getting adjusted to so all the
cities have lived have been really big
cities I lived in Lagos I lived in
London and how also is very beautiful
was a small smaller city compared to
leave us alone so that was a little bit
of a hard transition for me but what I
would say is the African community in
Stanford is extremely strong so that
served as a base
was encouragements while I went through
the transition and navigates it a little
bit anything for you I know you just
started a few months ago so maybe you're
still adjusting
yeah and I think I think I just feel a
little piddly when I said but I think it
was really it was really it was easier
than I expected and just that's just
because I think Stanford dedicates a lot
of resources to students and that's that
mix that's in a big transition really
easy I think the only thing has trouble
either was taking a 16-hour flight so
you guys have now spent over one year
each at Sanford and you're here for a
few months already
I would love to that you guys to just
discuss how being at Stanford has
changed the way you plan to either work
in Africa or how you plan to impact the
continent of Africa I think for me that
they get shift and I don't think it was
necessarily shift everything is just a
reinforcement so coming into Stanford
like the two things that were important
to me or technology and Africa but I
didn't really know how there's too much
and whether that whether that meant
working big tech in Africa but being in
Stanford giving there in Silicon Valley
I were just exposed to so much
technology innovative technology not so
innovative technology all sorts of
technology I feel like I have a much
better sense of what technology and
Africa mean for me and those two parts
of myself which almost parents coming
together I think someone's in is what
learned is it coming into Stanford I had
a FinTech background and all the things
I think about work in FinTech all the
ways in fact Africa for me was how can
fin tech change
X&Y industry and so coming here
interacting with people who've done so
many different things in different
industries who me was very eye-opening
and like now I'm looking at things like
a lecture mobility which I have no idea
I was interested in before and so just
being exposed to people not just the
gist people also
other stanford schools is hoping up my
mind the different opportunities that I
could leverage and then having for me
it's it's it's early days but probably
one of the biggest differences I'm
noticing is in the longest pieces I was
in before social impact is something
that people think about you know after
they've thought about how much money
they make and I think at Stanford
almost everyone across the different
graduate schools and and the student
themselves I think people think of
socially important and as not something
virtually exclusive from you know
running and commercially viable business
I think so I think almost everyone you
meet at Stanford is very conscious about
know just building a business building a
very sustainable business that is for
the greater good yeah I love that I
think also for me personally coming to
Stanford has been an amazing challenge
in a good way because we get to sit with
400 incredibly intelligent people who
think very differently about how
different problems can be solved and
your premonition or your previous ideas
on how to change the world
our challenge each and every day and so
for me personally I can definitely vouch
for what these three guys have said in
terms of coming here thinking I wanted
to change Africa in a specific way and
my specific way was through branding and
through products and then talking to
different people from athletes so who
people who are coming from the
entertainment industry so former
entrepreneurs who've been very
successful and and just sitting with
them and brainstorming with them and
thinking through different problems and
hearing them ask questions as people who
may not have lived on the continent are
not from the continent but I genuinely
curious about Africa has just been a way
for me to synthesize information
understand would actually care about and
know that it's extremely possible to
pursue whatever it is that you want to
pursue so that's that's been something I
loved about the GSB
so we'll take I'll give one more
question see you guys and the audience
you guys can continue to type in your
life questions I'm already seeing some
questions pop up here and then we'll
take some questions directly from the
audience but the last question I wanted
to ask you
before we give it over to the audience
is what have been some of your frame for
activities at the GSB so far can be fun
could be academic can be sleep I can go
I think it meets being the Africa
Business Forum the coach and that will a
medium whose amazing experience just
showcasing what the content has to offer
to people on campus and also interact
with so many business leaders academic
leaders from the continent either focus
there or working in the US as well was
just amazing to me you know I think not
to still cancel and I just add something
new I think we just have a unique
opportunity to almost be the conduit
between Silicon Valley and Africa and
you find yourself reaching that gap many
times while leading the conference and
that was just an exciting opportunity
for me to expose business leaders in
Silicon Valley are likewise exposed yeah
I think what I enjoyed most is there's a
lot of enterpreneurs and around the
syphon Valley they're investing in
Africa and for the earth could be
described to be able to bring these
rumors to campus every so often just to
speak to them that has been has been you
know quite impactful but I think
yesterday Nights was one of my days
encompasses and to see you know just the
different talent we had a sort of a fun
night where people from the business we
can showcase their their their talent
and I just you know have so many
classmates oh you know musically gifted
and and to even see Africans you know
get on stage and seeing and get so much
support from those yeah yeah I think you
guys have said everything funny enough
one of my favorite parts of Stanford are
the classes I know a lot of
but as an MP 8 - I love my classes like
going to class we do a lot of role plays
with just titans of industry Italy the
person teaching your vc class or your
venture capital class is somebody who
has been in venture capital for years
the person teaching your real estate
class is the CEO of what some of the
largest real estate or one of the
largest real estate companies in the
United States so that has just been very
humbling for me but also I just I just
can't believe every single day that I
get the opportunity to learn from such
amazingly talented and accomplished
people I'm so that's one of my favorite
things about about the GSB so now we'll
take questions from the audience so I'm
gonna hopefully I pronounced this
vertically burger puff on Sochi no and
the question is you mentioned that you
were an entrepreneur before the GSB and
then you mentioned that you interned for
Mackenzie and you plan to go back to
Mackenzie ages so what is it thinking
behind going from entrepreneurship to
consulting because usually it's
consulting too much furniture so I
started my own company right out of
undergrad and essentially teaching
myself everything on the job and coming
into the gist be I thought I was missing
certain skill sets that I thought large
corporate organizations the
superstructure to have massive training
programs would be great for me to learn
from and also I did choose to go to
consulting at McKinsey and I think I did
learn quite a bit over the summer and I
think is value me learning those things
for the next year and a half two years
and I think those would be super
valuable in in my company I was like
being brutally honest if you look at my
my resume if you don't know my companies
you'll not have an idea of if they've
good about companies right and there's a
huge film put on work and organizations
like gives you other organizations and I
think for me this value in in doing that
and sometimes people overlook that what
one stated but I think that's quite
important even on the constant so if
there was a way for me to together
amazing amazing thank you we have to ban
from Johannesburg and he wants to know
how do you go about finding a mentor at
the GSB
I think that's a good question I think
there are many different places where
you could find a mentor
actually there's you'd be surprised that
a lot of your classmates could even
access mentors because now that I'm
thinking actively about puts actually
starting something after business school
maybe in like a 1 year horizon after
graduating there are so many founders in
my class who I'm looking to commentar
ship to be able to guide me on the path
of being a first-time founder so that's
not professors as ruthless saying but
just it's so humbling to know the kind
of people who teach those classes on a
daily basis and give us access to their
networks give us access to all of the
acknowledge so I'm taking a class called
startup garage Lee I'm actually working
on my startup and the caliber of
professors startup gosh it's just
mind-blowing
I mean there's one of my professors who
I think I'm not sure what the exact
figure is has invested in and this is
someone that comes class every day is
actively helping us and that's also
another mentorship I can new if you are
you know looking for scholarships I
think tonight and I see scholarship yeah
is it good is it good when to apply
succeed because I've personally been
able to get a very good discouraged
because you know large array of members
of the advisory board and many of them
come from very different industries so
if you if you admitted into this
scholarship and there's an advisor who
sort of is interested in the same things
they're interested in then they'll reach
out and provided mentorship I think one
more Avenue is the alumni yeah I'm
pretty close to the first one in chat
with me comes the GSP
and you interact with so many alarms
over your time here and you develop some
keep relationships I think that's
another Apple
some good matches here amazing thank you
guys so we'll have a question from
Warren from South Africa again and
Warren wants to know if you found it
relatively easy to for you when in terms
of your internship for the summer so
this is a question from that medium
Kevin and so much of your internship for
the summer did you find it relatively
easy to get your first choice or did you
feel like you have to settle for your
second third and fourth choice okay you
go and I see them my my routes for my
internship I probably would recommend in
I'm sorry everyone's work specifically
for one of the graduates at X projects
called loon so yes and I would not
recommend that in hindsight but I'd
worked in consulting parts business
school I didn't have a profile that my
stand outs to X and I felt that I need
to put in a lot of work to prove that I
work there so what I meant for me was I
spent three months researching and
talking to people in the aerospace
technology immersing myself in space and
outside and so I'm just beginning but
you know having privy to some of your
experiences last year by meeting also
have worked extremely hard guys she
didn't just put it in the basket and
just let it sit there because I also
know that you took computer science
classes which takes a lot of time
specifically the schedule of the MBA
student so she definitely definitely
like put the eggs in one basket but you
made sure that it was very well made
sure that you were resume was was very
strong by the end of the year so yeah
yeah that's true
yeah and I wanted magnification to be an
application that would at least get a
callback yeah yeah I might be a extreme
end of that spectrum where I came in
with different ideas of what I wanted to
explore consulting was definitely very
close the job I flirted the idea of
investment banking venture capital tech
and I thought about applying to all
these these industries and all these
companies and you're gonna put me
realize that you can't devote as much
time and effort to applying to all these
and the application will not stand out
if you spread yourself too thin so I
focused on consulting for the internship
and yeah go to McKinsey so I'm glad I
did it was a great experience so we have
a question from David which I'm guessing
is from Nigeria but the questions that
asides from paga can you please talk
about other startups that have been
founded by African Stanford alum and can
you spotlight some PE firms in Africa
that are doing some interesting things
to develop the continent so you do not
let you take the PE question and then
let me do Kevin maybe you guys can talk
about startups and running companies
that you know how they found it by alum
okay besides Parker
I think this Nala in Tanzania there is a
VC in Kenya zipline here on Tomo
Triffids just be alums in addition like
from a social impact perspective the
entire L group African Leadership
Academy African Leadership University
all of this risk that does it up by
Stanford along the vein can I add to
this page a solar company called Alexa
no that's not veggies Vietnam there's
there's a soybean or Pioneer High
School's I think I think maybe I can I
can mention we see as well so I think a
already mentioned
so I'm gonna find big lot of times
anyway I think he's focusing a lot on
you know local entrepreneurs which is
you know a segment have been pretty much
ignored by much of the VC fund and the
other PC friend a convention is TL from
capital which has three GSB alum as
partners there I think on that PE side
it's it's I mean it's a sector that you
know there's a lot of excitement they
meet led to thousands and then what that
has pretty much deeps now that markets
are performing better so there's there's
a bit of you know negative feeling at
the moment
but you might think about the fungal I
think I doing a good job it's it's
pretty much the same names I think
development partners international
desert of London is perhaps you know has
been the best performing fund over run
and maybe Helios is probably the you
know bigger brand you know a bit of
performance if you don't lead with much
Helios TPI you can't go wrong I'm also
looking at a couple of funds like
actives in London and ethos are all
South Africa it's met a couple of
African MBAs winter they have a very
good a very good opinion of it and maybe
just to go to the other end I think
everyone looks at a very big funds but
there's some smaller funds and I'm very
a very good teams one of them run by
ESPN I cross boundary it's a pretty
decent team so maybe not that's you know
that big in science but a very decent
team and playing in a very in a Vegas
its vestiges of grid of great power yeah
I think one was always Africa fifty I
think the cool thing going quickly back
to the companies that have started by
just alarm is I think most of all of us
here have had the opportunity to
interact with at least two or three of
these founders and I think coming to
Stanford and now understand
looks like it's very clear that these
people were very positively affected by
the leadership training that you do get
at Stanford because it's the leadership
style speaks to a leader that you feel
cares about you and cares about the
impacts just as much as they care about
building a successful company that's
been my personal experience with these
alumni which was going back to the first
question one of the biggest reasons why
I personally chose to come to Stanford
so we're gonna take a question from
Korea from Egypt
so prettyy wants to travel to the United
States to visit Stanford University and
learn more about the MBA program in the
Stanford culture and his question is
when would you recommend that he visit I
would say that during that free Business
Forum clearly it's also doing spring
it's a beautiful time of year we'll give
you more details on African business
form before this this video is over but
that's personally the best time to come
Sam because you really get to see how
much the school has a play and has a
stake in on the continent you get to
interact with a lot of the African
students here you get to meet a lot of
amazing professors spring is a time
where people are just generally more
relaxed and their classes our classes
are just more fun the sun's out so yes
definitely anything else I also don't
want you to feel like you should come to
see the campus before you apply kinda
became here yes you would just be and
was a great decision on the list so you
don't feel obliged to come to visit
campus again hand yeah if you're in the
area if you want to come anyway like
feel free that's a good decision but
yeah don't feel obliged to yeah that's
such a great point because it doesn't do
anything for your application to come or
not come like zero the things for
applications coming ups come to the
campus so great point Kevin so let's
talk about this question about Silicon
Valley so Sandeep go mom wants to know
how involved are you guys in federal
with Silicon Valley and has it been easy
to promote African solutions and raise
funding if you tried or if you know
anybody who's tried
I think Silicon Valley before I can
Stanford could feel like a very nebulous
concept of what exactly where is it
their location I think coming to
Stanford I realized that Stanford as
they come by you kind of interpret
somebody is so embedded in Silicon
Valley
you're constantly exposed entrepreneurs
you're constantly was to BC investors
all of the things that makes this now
it's the second question around raising
money I know a little bit more about
this but I've spoken to African
entrepreneurs and they have been people
have been very successful like Cooper
360 around people that are raising money
I know that sometimes it takes a little
longer and sometimes you need to show a
bit more traction but I'm encouraged by
the fact that quite a few people have
done it and it just seems to be on the
rise yeah yeah yeah I also haven't tried
to raise here like I'm not active
exploring different ideas but I do know
Africans who raise funds while still in
school the one that comes to mind is is
Nalu join YC right out of the GSB I was
able to raise some funds so it is doable
I don't know if any of try it within the
class above ours but lutein broader acts
the class in general there's a lot of
people raised it's not I can add I think
the person who probably mentioned me a
lot and I was applying to Stanford is
from Kenya and I mean I can't mention
the company because this year to
officially launch it with I know like he
developed a peer is here and the funds
investors in the fund you know couple of
his professors a lot of testable
professors I know venture capital
investors and always looking yeah and
also thing just building off of that
Silicon Valley doesn't also just look
like feces it looks like going to big
tech and working on emerging markets
work within there I know let me do work
that loon I was at Google this summer
and I was so immersed in all of the
different opportunities that Google
provides any employee was interested in
pursuing some sort of initiative on the
continent whether that's taking a six
month externship just to pursue your own
idea within Google that's something that
company does I think other big tech
companies do that also speaking of Nala
and also speaking of some class of 2018
graduates I know who also founded a
company at in Kenya called Safi
analytics um
the Silicon Valley can also look like
some of your friends and classmates who
are very interested in supporting what
you're doing both from a mentorship
partnership perspective but sometimes
also from a financial perspective - so
we'll take probably one more question
and I love this question so this is from
odo so I'm Cara and the question says
what would you say stood out most in
your application and what advice would
you give future applicants and before
these three lovely people answer I would
just like to preface everything they say
by everybody's application is very
different you do not need to feel like
you need to copy somebody's specific
application to get there or that their
application is the best recipe for Han
to get to Stanford but I do think that
everybody story matters and it helps you
to kind of understand people's
experiences what they felt mattered to
them and as they were going through the
process of applying to the GSB thank you
go so I think to be honest I'm not under
percent sure what students in that
application but if I was to reflect a
little bit I think the world matters to
you the most x8 is a key part of the
application I mean this is so high sort
of application is like a portfolio of
different things like use my resume use
my recommendations to almost tell the
story of the achievements that I had had
those four and then the one matters to
me through a war matters to you the most
I see I used it as an opportunity to
just tell
the story of Lambie did behind the
achievements and it was just very I
think very real raw essay about what
matters to me the most without judgment
just stay tuned a tendency is not trying
to impress and I think that may have
been in ingredients but I would never
know what exactly got me here something
is really hard to know Alessi city life
comes with what work really likes about
your application but maybe if I if I
speak to what I think it's different you
know in my profile and you know ever has
I think so I think most Africans are
being you know only their country on the
continent that's that's that's one thing
the most of kind of in travel the Lord's
in Africa and I had to job that allowed
me to travel so much in vania African
countries I think probably worked in
almost 60 left in countries or different
projects and I think the the terms that
we chose able to speak about African
issues I think is probably different
from someone who's maybe just lived in
one part of Africa I think that's
something that came out in the
application thank me I can't point what
I thought was the most important part of
my application from the school's
perspective so I can't say what caught
me in but look at it from my perspective
at what I put in the most work in I
think was the one was most s Israel and
why I say that is when I was helped
immerse in the essay at some point I
picked it everything I said it typing
from scratch super raw essay and I said
tearing up when I was typing it on the
gap this is this but I do my password
quote mean or not it might be something
else but to me that's what I felt was
most important for me in the application
for me which is my ride telogen sand
just beauty no but I think similar to
what people are saying here I think our
our applications make sense in terms of
where we're coming from and what we want
to do and it probably showed a lot that
we thought really intentional
about what we want to do with a business
degree at Stanford and why we want to do
those things and so I think the biggest
thing that I'm getting from this panel
is just the idea of authenticity and not
feeling like you need to be somebody
different to get into Stanford and
everybody talked about writing real and
raw essays they're talking about your
actual experiences and that was
definitely my my experience as well so
we're gonna take one more sort of
general question and then we'll sort of
close this out so we are getting a lot
of questions about what financial aid
looks like at the GSB so I'll just I'll
just kind of cap and umbrella everything
by saying if you don't already know that
GSB offers need-based fellowships and
not necessarily not merit merit-based
fellowships
but the need-based fellowships are very
generous and are based on sort of an
objectively scaled system that the GSB
runs also there are other ways to fund
or and be a program like the Matt
Hennessy scholarship I know for example
in Nigeria they're different
organizations and corporations that
offer different types of full
scholarships I'm imagining that some may
exist on other countries on the
continent but I would definitely say
that the biggest one of the one of the
best things I did was having a mind
switch and thinking about the GSB from a
debt perspective and more from an
investor's perspective and I think that
that just helps you to ease your mind
because what you get by mere default of
being on this campus is a huge
investment that yields opportunities for
you for years to come but you can
definitely go on the GSB destined for
not edu to find out more about what
financial aid looks like for for you as
an individual planning to apply for next
year and the years to come so the last
question last group of questions I'm
getting actually having less to do with
student life people want to know what
student life is like culture what do you
do on a typical Thursday Friday
so just rapidly let's go about and talk
about maybe what you're you know
favorite pastime is or something that's
really fun for you I think we talked
about a lot of serious things so people
want to know if we have fun or not
yeah we have which is difficult since
the schedules always super packed you
mentioned like to me that Thursday is my
my busiest day at 8 a.m. to 9 p.m. of
classes and then there's I take time to
myself it's I mean even struggles you
know how do you spread yourself across I
probably had to make it to four
different events after 7 p.m. so it's
it's it gets you know I casually I think
the continued strong for use most of the
first year students leave you know right
next to the compass and it to rest in
never the GSB has so it's you know you
can't really know each other and and you
know I'll always think they were
happening a really close to you and and
I think just the beauty of being in
California Ivy Tech you know one or two
hour drive in whatever direction you
know there's you know a beach or a
mountain people are always planning
those kind of things and so that that
makes it really very funny
yeah and I think just add to what these
guys have said I think one thing that
comes to mind for me is I love the fact
that in Stanford you can really be who
you are exactly there's some people that
I'd love to go to BPL every week or good
suit form which is like a huge party and
that's fine and there's a community
around that there are people like me who
are a little bit more introverts and I
like having people over for dinner or
what you move these are people in my
house and that's perfectly fine too and
there's no pressure to be either or both
are accepted and supports it
so that's what I've loved yeah one thing
for me that I'll highlight is traveling
at the GSD it's been such a fun
experience traveling with different
classmates and I think so maybe a
stereotype about business school is that
you're traveling to you know amazing
places in a
Australia and all these places but
people have very interesting travelling
trips that they do whether that's oh
we're all going to travel to Jordan to
volunteer for not-for-profit
organisations together or we're gonna
travel to Cuba which was a really fun
trip where we're gonna go to New Zealand
and and do really amazing things or
we're gonna go to Austin Texas for South
by Southwest which is a huge music
festival that happens every year people
just find different things that interest
them find groups of people with similar
interests or people that are just
interested in traveling with you and
that has been such an amazing fun
experience they really get off campus
get out of the state sometimes get to
know people in a very different space
and really get to build what I would
think are some of the strongest bonds
that we can build with our classmates
not being in our in our element and you
know fun is what you make it I think you
can be in Vegas and not have fun because
you're a boring person or you can be in
your home on a Saturday night and having
the best of fun because you just make it
that way
so I would say that business school in
general is definitely a place where you
can have as much fun as you want and
still be as focused as you want and we
can provide a little bit more detail
later as you guys start to apply so I
just wanted to make one last comment
which is that a lot of people want to
know how they can connect with African
business club so you can connect with
African business through the GSB to
Stanford edu
and like all of these guys have
mentioned and I've also mentioned that
African business forum is really an
event that helps you to connect with us
on a really fun weekend in the spring is
I think it really loved it this year and
we're super excited because this comp
this forum brings around some of the
most intelligent minds thought partners
policymakers business moguls from from
the continent to really come in and
inspire and challenge us here in the Bay
Area in the center of Silicon Valley so
we're super excited for the conference
to be held again in the spring this year
so as we sort of come around to a close
I wanted everybody just to go around and
give your words of wisdom
to all of the amazing people listening
right now as they're getting ready to
apply to Stanford it could be about
anything you want it to be but what
would you tell hundreds of our listeners
right now about student life applying to
Stanford the best advice you can give
them anything I can start so I think I
think one thing that I did a lot was I
even before I find Stanford there's so
many times where I thought I would never
get it and I think a lot of people don't
even end up applying I know you guys on
the call which is a step in the right
direction but a lot of people have to
serve these calls I felt the same now
just like I'm never gonna get in and I
find that Africans much generalized
major and specifically which I know
people have spoken to just opt after the
process and think that you know I don't
have the profile I haven't done anything
amazing but I would just encourage you
to believe yourself apply for your best
foot forward reach out to any of us if
you need help because we're all about
getting more Africans come to GS e so
any of us if you need help please do it
by yourself I think when I say that this
there's a lot of reason how to apply and
if you're going to look for those
reasons not to apply find a lot of them
and I did find out about them I remember
one time really initially Stern voice
and Kwan's of you know what business do
I have applying in the first place so I
think people are really different
everything is different is this goodness
in everyone so I think I just do some
soul searching and find that's both that
strength that you have and we do break a
Stanford and focus on that and I'd say
for people worrying about you know am I
will I be able to afford eat I think I'd
say focus on getting in and you'll be
surprised as how much how hard school to
the work to make sure you can afford it
after you get admitted so that was my
first point
my second one my third is if you apply
that just be yourself to be super
authentic don't try to be someone else
as with mentioned everyone has value
they bring to this community don't be
afraid they don't have the background
everyone else has be comfortable in what
you've done and there's a place where I
go everything they said so I just want
to thank our panelists Lonnie day
Eugenia Kevin for taking time out of
their schedule to speak to you guys feel
free to reach out to us at GSP deaf
stanford.edu and we appreciate you guys
so much we can't wait to see a lot of
you guys a lot more of you guys in the
coming years at the GSB so thank you all
very much
[Music]